il faut un peu de hauteur pour mieux
prendre conscience de l'ampleur des
travaux
une inspection menée par catherine dont
le constat est sans appel niveau des
drisses
ça fait un petit peu d'usure donc
faudrait peut-être songer à l'est à
l'échangé des drisses des poulies et des
veaux à la renouveler un carénage a
effectué sans compter l'achat d'une
remorque des dépenses faramineuses qui
oblige l'équipage a bricolé un maximum
[Applaudissements]
de réparer pour faire durer le matériel
le plus longtemps possible soit de
brouillard un rafistolage qui dure
depuis trop longtemps
bientôt quatre ans que douvan le
surprise entièrement féminin n'a pas
subi de travaux majeurs malgré les
sponsors les finances ne suivent plus la
question s'est même posé arrêté ou
poursuivre l'aventuré ya plein de gens
sur l'eau qui nous apprécient qui nous
encouragent qui sont épatés et je le
suis la première est épaté de tout ce
qu'on arrive à faire contre filles on
arrive à faire l'entretien de notre
bateau ont fait nous prépare nos régates
on s'occupe de tout de façon autonome
les filles ont besoin de dix mille euros
pour remettre à flot l'embarcation
elles ont déjà collecté le tiers de la
somme et il leur reste un mois pour
atteindre leur objectif les
compétitrices espère ainsi se remettre
rapidement l'entraînement avant les
premières régates de l'année